welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david today and tomorrow
well we also have to talk you know we've
talked a lot about republican extremists
we've talked january 6 donald trump all
of that
we got to get to some issues here folks
and of course one of the biggest issues
facing americans today
is inflation
you know whether it's gas prices or
goods services everything out there
inflation is absolutely crippling
the united states economy
and according to a new report from the
roosevelt institute
a lot of this uh
if inflation
if you want to call it that
is actually rooted in nothing more than
corporate greed
now that's not to say that inflation is
not happening right now at a staggering
and alarming rate it is
but it's happening all over the world
not just here in the united states
this is not a u.s problem this is a
global supply issue
but here in the united states we do have
something a little bit unique
we have what is being called now greed
flation
and that greed flation is corporations
of course jacking up prices beyond
what inflation is forcing them to pay
and passing that on to consumers
it's a very simple scam and to be honest
corporations many ceos executives
they've actually admitted to doing this
in interviews over the past year
they have said on the record that times
of high inflation are the perfect time
for companies to raise their prices
anyway
one because they don't get blamed for it
but two inflation eventually goes away
you know sometimes it lasts a little
longer you know but
eventually the prices will go back down
and when people start seeing the price
tags go back down they get happy they're
like oh boy it's over
and then eventually the price will
settle somewhere that will be more than
what it was before the period of
inflation but lower than what it was
with inflation so consumers think they
win
but that difference between the
pre-inflation
price and the post-inflation price
that
is the corporate price gouging
and again this new report from the
roosevelt institute says that corporate
price gouging right now
based on profits
based on what they're paying these
corporations
with inflation and then passing on to
consumers is the worst level it has been
in the united states since the 1950s
so it's been roughly 70 years most
people alive today
have never seen corporate price gouging
as bad as it is and of course this was
just for the year 2021
because we don't have final numbers from
2022 because we're only halfway through
the year
so this report was only looking at last
year
when inflation and price gouging was not
as bad as it has been so far this year
if you want to know a good example look
at tyson foods tyson foods recently
released you know their their
quarterly report
in their quarterly report
they showed that inflation had caused
their uh costs to go up i'm just going
to make up numbers because i don't
remember exactly
but i do remember the percentages so
trust me
let's say their costs went up 1.5
billion
but the prices they raised for consumers
wasn't 1.5 billion it was 2 billion
so there's a 500 million dollar gap in
there that is nothing more
than corporate greed raising prices
simply for the fact that they can
and again those weren't the exact
numbers but it was the correct
percentages there was a 25
increase so
what we're looking at
is a time when the united states more
than ever needs a windfall profit tax
on these corporations whether it's the
oil industry
whether it's the grocery stores
manufacturers
car manufacturers doesn't matter a
windfall profits tax
could put an end to this corporate price
gouging that is crushing americans every
time they go shopping doesn't matter
what they go shopping for
and believe it or not this corporate
windfall profit tax is now supported by
a majority
of american citizens a majority of them
want this windfall profits tax
it's a simple solution
it's a simple solution to a growing
problem that affects the wallets of
everybody in this country rich and poor
alike
it obviously affects the poor a lot more
than it affects the rich
but everybody's paying higher prices
the windfall profits tax
could put an end to that
we just have to have legislators with
the courage to actually do this
and unfortunately we do not have enough
of them
instead we get ideas from biden like
coming out this week like oh what about
a gas tax holiday cool you're gonna save
the average american family three
dollars and sixty cents a week
those are the numbers folks three
dollars and sixty cents a week is what
you would probably end up saving on
average the average family actually
if you fill up your tank once a week and
you got a 20 gallon tank
that three dollars and sixty cents isn't
going to change your life at all
honestly it's not even going to help you
i'm sorry but it's not you can't even
buy a gallon of milk with that because
of inflation and corporate price gouging
so that's a bad idea especially because
that money is actually used to fund
infrastructure and hey we're already
having trouble spending our
infrastructure bill money because of
inflation
so all those infrastructure projects
that we were promised they've been put
on hold because the prices are so dang
high
we're just getting screwed every which
way you look at it
and all of it comes right back to that
issue of corporate greed